investing in crypto or certainly
gambling in crypto oh boy who
the big diesel oh shaq
shaq says uh
he's in everything and he's in
everything okay
so since retiring from the nba in 2011
shaq is amassed a net worth of
400 million dollars he's doing all right
okay he's all in on five guys he's got
uh auntie annie's he's got 24-hour
fitness gyms he's doing his thing yeah
okay but one thing he's not invested in
crypto he's steering clear of the crypto
world and the the the answer is he
doesn't understand that he says that
says i don't understand it so i'll
probably stay away from it until i get a
full understanding of what it is now
shaq's not a dummy jack is a pretty
smart guy he actually took people's time
to him exactly he actually took the time
to um
to learn it
i think you would learn it you're good
you need to i'm good i'm good i'm good
i'm good i think you'll get you know
shaq does a thing every year called the
shack tank
where investors come in and pitch him
they got like 15 minutes to come in and
pitch him ideas all he needs is someone
to basically come in and uh
pitch him on some crypto ideas i think
he'll learn
so but but basically he's saying look
i'm not in the crypto but i'm not going
to hate on you if you're doing it right
so like tom brady's doing something with
crypto steph curry's doing stuff with
crypto he got a the running back from
the giants uh saquon barkley's doing now
every athlete's doing something with the
nfts ronaldo messi right pele did
something with nfts everyone's doing but
but shaq says i ain't with this
crypto stuff he's saying he's basically
weary here's his thing he's weary of
overnight success and the stories that
um that surround all these
cryptocurrencies overnight success which
there's a lot of them right so he says
quote unquote every time somebody tells
me one of those great stories
i like it
but from my experience it may be too
good to be true so you know my takeaway
is this look if everyone around you is
doing well with crypto and nobody's
telling you
yeah i lost all my money in crypto yeah
then there's weary there's probably
something you should be weary about they
might not tell you the whole truth so if
you're only hearing success stories
about crypto you may be doing to do a
little research i'm sure people are out
there there's a hundred million
different stories both ways but crypto
is obviously the hot thing these days
um but shaq says i don't care i'm not
jumping on the trend i'm out on that
talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken